spoiler-free review of black panther 2
by the way isn't this wakanda jersey
dope I'm not going to tell you guys
where I got it from but I bought it so I
could do the review on this and it was
also really really badass like I just I
had to get it it just looks super dope
so black panther 2 right first things
first that people are going to ask how
does the movie handle the passing of
Chadwick Boseman they do it very
Tastefully and they do it very well I
absolutely love the way it was handled
having said that I know that coming out
of basically Chadwick boseman's whole
run in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
before he passed away a lot of people
were probably going to be asking the
question can this movie succeed without
Chadwick Boseman playing t'challa the
answer is absolutely resolutely yes it
is a great movie it's an emotional
roller coaster 20 minutes into this film
and I'm just like bro like I'm kind of
struggling right I'm just like man like
it's it's hard not to cry because it's a
very very emotional moment right it's an
emotional thing when they deal with
Chadwick boseman's passing in the actual
film itself having said that all the
other characters shine in a way that you
probably didn't think they would have
been able to do right where you were
just kind of like wow look at like how
look at everything these characters
bring to the table I love the way it was
done right basically if you if you look
at the movie for what it is there is a
kind of main star to a degree but the
reality is it just feels like a bunch of
main stars it's an ensemble cast and
where normally you would look at a movie
like that and you would feel like the
movie would be all disheveled it'd be
all over the place nobody would really
understand what's going on with
anybody's story everyone's story is tied
together it's intertwined and is also
handled in a really amazing way now also
again not a major spoiler I won't reveal
an identity here but as you guys know
from the trailer we do get a new black
panther that person's story in becoming
the New Black Panther is amazing I'm not
even gonna lie to you guys I honestly
think that for a single film it's the
best storytelling that's been done for
us for like an end individual character
just their Journey right just for a
singular character it's some of the best
storytelling ever that's that's ever
been done the other thing that I also
want to throw out here and I might make
a separate video where I talk about this
and offer my thoughts on it this is what
phase four should have been to be honest
with you guys it should have been
She-Hulk it shouldn't have even been
Loki or Juan division honestly One
Division maybe that should have been a
movie Loki should have been a TV show or
film in Phase five no Spider-Man no way
home no doctor strange too this is what
it should have done what this movie did
right the the overall feel of this movie
is the events of infinity war in
Avengers in-game are not lost they are
felt to a degree but the bigger feeling
here is the sense of loss from Chadwick
boseman's t'challa and so that kind of
overrunning theme when it comes to this
film is really what the theme of phase
four should have been the feeling of
loss but the feeling of rebirth because
that's what this is right it's death and
rebirth that's really what this whole
thing is about so again you know it's
it's really really cool how the whole
thing is handled there are some familiar
faces from over the course of the MCU
that will appear in this movie there's
one character who appeared and totally
took me by surprise those of you guys
who saw the movie you know who I'm
talking about the aftermath of like the
first fight like you guys know the
person that I'm talking about and it was
just like as soon as they appeared I was
like what and I was like okay so the MCU
is serious they're going in that
direction and I'm really excited to see
what direction it goes in but uh but
that person they initially seemed seem
kind of silly so I will say do not be
tricked by how that person puts
themselves out there because they're a
lot more capable than they initially
lead you to believe they are but of
course again there's other familiar
faces that show up it's really really
cool
um again you know the the the situation
itself the story itself is kind of hard
not to spoil or not not to go into
detail without too much spoiler but what
I do want to talk about here is name or
the Submariner because I feel like
that's the thing that people want to
know about right how does the Marvel
Cinematic Universe handle handle Namor
let me tell you something I have never
in my life given a
shot name of the Submariner right if it
had been before this movie and you had
been like hey Rob what are your thoughts
on name of the Submariner I'm like he's
basically Marvel's Aquaman right like he
was on The Avengers sometimes he talks
to fish like the guy's not that
interesting he's only had two cool
moments in Marvel Comics that was when
he destroyed wakanda in Avengers vs
X-Men and then when Black Panther kind
of killed him but not really by blowing
up a world that he was on in Jonathan
Hickman's Avengers I'm sorry Donna
Hickman's Avengers The New Avengers
storyline those are the only two times
he's ever been cool this movie elevated
the name of the Submariner to the top of
my list of characters that I think are
badass this dude is a [ __ ] Beast dude
it's amazing they're the scenes where he
showed man
you guys remember oh my God man do you
guys remember the fight like you guys
like the first time he shows up like not
the first time you see him for the first
time you see him fight sun sun right it
was it was oh my God it was it was saw
it was so badass it's one of the coolest
moments right it's one of the coolest
things not gonna spoil anything but he
unleashes health and it's just him it's
just one guy right it's just it's agent
do you guys remember that scene from
from Daredevil when like Daredevil goes
to like the the meat packing plant right
the butcher Place whatever it is and
like he pulls the guy off the meat hook
and Matt Murdoch's like you know who did
this tell me who they were and the guy's
like no they one man right it was him it
was one guy that's Neymar in this movie
man like it is it's it's it's it's
phenomenal man because there's this
there's this point in the movie when
like the guy when it looks like they've
got him down right looks like he looks
like he's defeated you know and it's
just like nah man like like you can kind
of tell like no dude this guy's just
getting warmed up right like it's like
it's like it's like it's like El
president said in that Sandy ravage
video from back in the day like you
didn't beat him you just pissed him off
and now you [ __ ] cause now he's gonna be
out for blood that's basically what this
is right like that's it's it's like
Neymar was phenomenal and his story is
amazing oh my God his kingdom looks
beautiful it looks absolutely gorgeous
it's it's it looks absolutely phenomenal
just the whole name or thing right the
whole name or element is just this
incredible thing in the movie I
absolutely loved it you guys can also
tell by my excitement about name or the
Submariner what likely happens with his
character right you know it's it's for
those of guys who are hoping right now I
don't know if this is really a spoiler
but I feel like this is what people want
to hear he doesn't die right that's all
I'm gonna give you that's it I'm excited
to see where Neymar goes but his his
character brings a lot to the Marvel
Cinematic Universe but it's not overt
it's not one of those things where he's
like hi my name's name of the Submariner
and this and this and this and this and
this he does give an exposition you do
learn where he comes from you do learn
the nature of his powers and his
abilities to a degree but he expands on
the MCU and it's amazing right so so
overall I loved the movie I thought the
movie was beautifully shot it was it was
exciting the Marvel Cinematic Universe
feels like it's back if I'm if I'm being
honest with you guys right pound for
pound shot for shot minute for minute
this is the the best film that they
released in phase four it's better than
Spider-Man no way home certainly better
than Dr Strange 2 Multiverse of Madness
it is unequivocally better than Thor
right or Thor wasn't Thor love and
thunder also for those of you guys who
were who didn't like Gore the god
Butcher and who are afraid that the
Marvel Cinematic Universe is going to
give name of the Submariner the gore the
god butcher treatment
fret not they don't this guy don't you
are if you're a name with a Submariner
fan you're going to be like name or
represent that's exactly how you're
gonna feel man like you are gonna you're
gonna
move so badass I'm so excited to see
what happens with them in the future but
anyway guys we're gonna bring this video
to an end I'm done ranting thank you all
for watching make sure you guys check
out black panther 2 and I will catch you
all later peace